[Music]
it was an emotional red carpet reunion
for Margot Robbie and Tonya Harding at
the I Tonya premiere last night and
Tonya she was really enjoying the moment
that was an iconic red carpet moment
right there and Margot looked stunning
in gold Versace very Michelle Pfeiffer
Scarface fifoota fright stunning well
earlier I sat down with Margo who told
me that this film shows the sight of
Tanya that we have never seen before I
was amazed that no one had really asked
about her upbringing has circumstances
everyone just so quickly to call her
white trash and turn her into this
monster in in in the media I was shocked
channeling that emotion into a stunning
performance in AI Tonya Margot says the
film's mission is to humanize one of the
most villainized figures in American
sports history when I was a kid did you
ever love me or anything poor you I
didn't stay home making Apple brown
Betty's no I made you a champion your
monster spilled milk baby the film is
told from the perspective of Tanya and
the alleged abusers in her life her
mother played by Allison Janney and her
ex-husband and masterminds of the Nancy
Kerrigan attack played by Sebastian Stan
they both have denied allegations of
abuse was there any specific footage
that you researched a lot for Tanya this
documentary made about it when she was
15
she's speaking very candidly my
relationship with my mom is really bad
she's a good mother but she's not a good
mother she hits me and she being Queen I
guess she assumed that no one was really
gonna see that footage it was
heartbreaking that no one really
listened when she said things like my
mom beats me
Tanya's mother Levana was also featured
in that 1986 documentary sharp edges if
there's no you can't do hi Tanya
masterfully replicated her unique look
burden all
let's talk a little bit about the
physical transformation what kind of
friggin person bashes in their friend's
knee yeah so obviously Tonya in her old
years we were trying to portray like a
significant weight gain and that
required prosthetics and when I play
Tonya at 15 I put the short hair in the
braces then like a Tonya in her 20s I
think the skate costumes were just so
fun we actually finally enough did a lot
of counter contouring makeup to try and
alter my face shape to look more like
Tonya wait was Tanya's reaction to the
finished film
she said she laughed and she cried and I
get the sense that she felt somewhat
vindicated that her side of the story
was finally told well this film is
awesome it is one of my favorites of the
year and it also marks Margo's first as
lead actress and for her production
company plus her husband Tom also
happens to be her producing partner talk
about keeping it in the family
yeah a lot of creativity at home
[Music]
you